I can't remember not being conscious of
race I i guess i'd have to have been pre
lingual because even though most of the
people around me were african-american
people um there was still a sense when
you went into other parts of baltimore
that there were white people or for
example my grandmother my maternal
grandmother took my brother and I to
enrolled us in a camp when I was eight
and he was six and everybody in that
camp was white except for one
african-american girl my brother had
blue eyes and blonde hair so people
didn't always know that he was black and
so you know I was very conscious in that
camp of not being white and I was eight
years old then so I think it's something
that in my generation is pretty deeply
ingrained I don't think that my niece
who is 9 has the same experience that I
don't I don't think she's conscious but
I don't think she's self-conscious in
the way that I was because the message
to us was that it was something that you
know wasn't necessarily that great and
so you had to count on the people in
your family in your your church and the
people who were closer to you to try to
make sense of that